- Mm-hmm. All right.
Hey, palsies!
My name is Cody,
and I'm a Helpster.
That means a monster who helps.
And because I love, love, love
to help so much,
I'm making these videos called...
There are so many people
helping us right now,
and I wish there was a way
we could say thank you to all of 'em.
Well, guess what?
There are so many ways!
You could write a letter,
or send a card or a drawing,
or you can make a video
like I'm doing right now.
Or you could sing them a song.
And you could get
some friends to help, like...
Grouplove!
- GROUPLOVE: Hey!
- Hey, Grouplove!
Hey, you got your instruments
all ready to make some music?
- No. No, we don't.
- What? No? But-but-but-but--
- We thought we'd loop sounds
to make music instead.
Right, everybody?
- Yeah!
- Yeah.
- Ah! I love that idea!
You know, my friends and I
loop sounds all the time.
Oh, loop means
to do something again and again.
- Okay, everybody, so when Cody
says so, let's loop our sounds.
- Yes, please,
and then please stop looping
when Christian and Hannah and I
stop singing. Got it?
- ALL: Got it.
- Oh, oh, and everybody
watching at home,
feel free to clap along, huh?
Okay, start us off, Benjamin.
- (beatboxes)
- Daniel, go!
- (vocalizing)
- All right, Andrew.
Come on in.
- (vocalizing)
- ♪ There are
lots of things we need ♪
♪ Even when we're mostly
staying at home ♪
- ♪ And 100 kinds of work ♪
♪ That would be difficult
to do on our own ♪
- ♪ We need packages and mail,
need food on our plate ♪
- ♪ We need medicine and care
when we're not feeling so great ♪
- ♪ We need working electricity ♪
♪ So we can call our friends
on the phone ♪
- ♪ And say we're not alone ♪
- ♪ Somebody's out there
for me and for you ♪
♪ Somebody who can run
to the trouble ♪
♪ 'Cause that's what they do ♪
♪ But don't worry,
you can do something too ♪
- ♪ Sing a song
and say thank you ♪
- Thank you,
health care workers.
- ♪ Sing a song
and say thank you ♪
- Thank you, delivery people.
- ♪ Sing a song
and say thank you ♪
- Thank you, firefighters
and police officers.
- ♪ Sing a song
and say thank you ♪
- There are so many
other people I wanna thank too,
like-like-like
transportation workers,
and grocery workers,
and teachers and janitors
and volunteers and-and-and--
- Well, I guess what
I'm really trying to say is,
thank you to everyone who's keeping us
safe and happy and healthy.
Oh, and a special thanks
to all the kids
who are giving grown-ups
a helping hand.
I am so proud of you.
Now if you'll excuse me,
I'm gonna go see
if there are even more ways
I can help,
and I hope you'll do the same.
Bye!